So, then you continue the question. You are already taking the premier research labs
preventing tumor plus and standard process tumor at 4-take. There is some tumor
rick also in the sun fiber. Can you get too much tumor rick? Not unless you have a
mood sensitivity to tumor really you can't get too much tumor. A lot of studies
for cancer and tumor rick. This is given that even if person doesn't have any
genetic defects suggesting maybe wanting to use more tumor rick. Talk about
anywhere between two to ten grams of tumor. That's a whole lot. So that's why
this can be good to get it in bulk and it had just had some bulk tumor that you
could even buy at the health food store that you could hand you a smoothie. It
can be really good. Also, you said to use a hot compress over my liver for
13 to 15, 15, 15 to 30 minutes a day. Do you mean with or without cast or oil? Yes
it's exactly what I mean with they're without cast or oil. And the reason why I
say that is that I'm not trying to add more burden to you. So yes, if you do it
with cast or oil, that's even better. But a lot of times if I say do a 15 to
30 minute cast or oil pack over your liver every day, some people just won't
take it. Just they just won't do it. I get it. I understand human nature well
enough to say if I add too much people will just not do it. So if you have the
ability to do cast or oil, then do it. But if you're like really busy and you're
just sat down and you're tired and you just sat down and you're gonna watch a
show or something like that. But you have a hot pack sitting by the chair that
you sat at, just grab the hot pack and turn the thing on. So use the heating pad,
the UTK far infrared heating pad. That's the one we have at home. So just use that,
don't think I have to get up with a new glass to oil or I can't do it at all. Okay. So
don't don't put that burden on. So cast or oil pack is better, but heating pack is
better than that good in it all.